[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit kai
selbe richter und christian sievers
guten abend in allen beim ringen ums
klima hat die welt überstunden gemacht
und einen deal geschafft fast 200
staaten auf der uno-konferenz in glasgow
einigten sich am späten abend auf einen
abschluss erklärung die drängt und warnt
und
festlegt aber sie allein wird die großen
herausforderungen nicht lösen zumal der
text an manchen stellen in letzter
minute noch einmal aufgeweicht wurde es
bleibt eine herausforderung auch für uns
alle die das beobachten der teufel liegt
im detail und nicht die konferenz rettet
unseren planeten sondern die
gewissenhafte umsetzung konkreter
beschlüsse wo wir stehen heute abend
nach glasgow zeigen volker angriffs und
marco
darauf hat nicht nur der
konferenzpräsident alabama gewartet
endlich ist das schlussdokument der
glasgow climate pact einstimmig
angenommen auf diese punkte haben sich
die knapp 200 staaten geeinigt
klimapläne müssen nun jährlich
nachgebessert werden statt bisher alle
fünf jahre kein ausstieg aus der
kohleverstromung nur herunterfahren
indien hatte interveniert notwendigkeit
den entwicklungsländern deutlich mehr
geld für klimaschutz und
schadensausgleich zu gewähren das
regelbuch über die vergleichbarkeit von
klimadaten ist vollendet und beschlossen
wir haben zu beginn der verhandlungen
hier gesagt wir wollen dass alle noch
ausstehenden beschlüsse alle rechtstexte
abgeschlossen werden dass das geröll
dieser rechts verhandlungen aus dem weg
ist damit wir uns nun beschleunigt auf
den weg machen können in die umsetzung
das ist alles gelungen heftiger
schlagabtausch noch heute nachmittag im
plenum der eu klimakommissarin deutlich
himmels willen verderben sie diesen
moment nicht bitte nehmen sie diesen
entwurf an klima-aktivisten und
vertreter vieler umweltschutzverbände
sorgten zwei wochen lang durch
demonstrationen und protestaktionen für
aufmerksamkeit machten politischen druck
so wurde australien einmal mehr die
zweifelhafte ehrung fossil des tages
verliehen
das ende der konferenz war ein
spiegelbild dessen was wir in den ganzen
zwei wochen erlebt haben der einen seite
ist sich die welt einig dass wir die
globale erwärmung unter 15 grad
stabilisieren müssen um wirklich
menschenleben zu retten und auf der
anderen seite sind wirtschaftsinteressen
in der kohleindustrie in der ölindustrie
diejenigen die hier progressive
entscheidungen zurückhaltend die jetzt
unmittelbar wirksam sind das dokument
gibt den nationen ansehnliche
klimapolitische hausaufgaben auch
deutschland nicht nur beim kohleausstieg
meine deutsche umweltverbände
so müsse sich zum beispiel die deutsche
außenpolitik neu ausrichten
dafür brauchen das umweltministerium das
entwicklungsministerium in das
auswärtige amt mandat finanzielle
ausstattung und personelle ausstattung
um die notwendigen klima und kohle
ausstiegs partnerschaften mit den großen
schwellenländern jetzt verhandeln zu
können glasgow ist geschichte jetzt
kommt es auf die umsetzung an und die
wird seit heute jährlich überprüft also
erstmals im november 2022 auf der 27
klimakonferenz dann in ägypten der
uno-generalsekretär sagt heute die
klimakatastrophe steht weiter vor der
tür versuchen wir eine schlussbilanz
volker gemessen an dem was glasgow
schaffen sollte leicht dass jetzt
müssen wir es erstmal ein bisschen
sortieren glasgow die klimakonferenz
sind ja nicht angetreten um hier einen
klimaschutz schalter umzulegen sondern
das was zu erreichen war nämlich die
ganzen vertraglichen die rechtlichen
dinge abzuarbeiten nachdem paris
abkommen das ist heute gelungen das hat
ja auch der umwelt staatssekretär eben
im beitrag bestätigt und jetzt geht es
eigentlich erst richtig los jetzt fängt
die umsetzung an das reicht überhaupt
noch nicht für das 1,5 grad limit aber
der weg ist jetzt frei und jetzt kommt
es darauf an dass alle länder wirklich
ernst machen mit echten klimaschutz
jetzt kommt es darauf an was sind denn
jetzt die größten arbeitsaufträge aus
glasgow für die künftige regierung in
deutschland
naja erstmals und einige nennen das
historisch steht in einem un dokument
das das kohle zeitalter zu ende ist der
ausstieg ist zwar nicht ganz so hart
formuliert worden ist es ja jetzt in der
tat nur ein herunterfahren aber immerhin
das ist ein klares signal und ich denke
dass auch deutschland den kohleausstieg
überprüfen muss 20 38 ist ja für uns da
gibt es ein gesetz zu das ist eine
aufgabe für die nächste regierung da
noch mal nachzuschauen ob das nicht noch
ein bisschen schneller geht und
gleichzeitig anderen ländern zu helfen
das auch zu tun in deutschland hat eine
partnerschaft mit südafrika und heute
neu dazugekommen eben aus diplomatischen
gründen um das hinzubekommen ist indien
damit eingestiegen einbezogen worden und
das wäre natürlich sehr sehr gut gute
signale wenn das insgesamt dann zu mehr
verzicht auf kohlestrom kommen könnte
vielen dank volker angriffs live aus
glasgow und dann hören wir doch was die
grünen-chefin dazu sagt annalena
baerbock ist live bei uns im
heute-journal guttenberg
sie müssen jetzt glasgow in ihrem
koalitionsvertrag reinschreiben ja für
was konkret für welche punkte konkret
haben sie denn die zusage von spd und
fdp ja wir verhandeln ja noch aber diese
klimakonferenz die hat die heftigkeit
der klima bedrohung endlich anerkannt
aber noch lange nicht gebannt auch weil
eine deutsche bundesregierung so an der
seite stand gerade beim
verbrennungsmotor aus wofür sie auch
eine allianz in glasgow gab das wurde
von deutschland nicht mitgezeichnet und
das ist eines der großen projekte was
nächste bundesregierung machen muss den
ausstieg aus den fossilen
verbrennungsmotor auf den weg zu bringen
und genau so wie er korrespondent herr
anderes gerade gesagt hat der
kohleausstieg der muss deutlich früher
kommen wenn die welt insgesamt ist zur
mitte des jahrhunderts klimaneutral
werden sie ja dann müssen die
industriestaaten auf werbung der
kohleausstieg muss deutlich früher
kommen sagen sie jetzt sind sie aber
nicht mehr opposition also man ist
möglicherweise bald nicht mehr dh wird
denn der kohleausstieg mit den grünen
garantiert früher kommen können sie das
heute abend so ankündigen ja ja und das
ist dann auch der knackpunkt also sprich
wenn die beiden anderen in ihrer
koalition da nicht mitmachen was
passiert dann
ja dann würden wir das pariser klima
abkommen brechen und da der gesamt der
deutsche bundestag vor sechs jahren das
pariser klima abkommen unterzeichnet hat
jetzt in glasgow wo die dieser
klimavertrag noch mal nachgeschärft hat
die welt deutlich gemacht man muss aus
der kohle aussteigen und die
industriestaaten dazu gehört die
europäische union dazu gehören
deutschland hier stehen zuvor das in der
verantwortung und für mich ist das
auftrag auch in einer neuen
bundesregierung nicht nur dafür zu
sorgen dass wir auf den 15 grad fahrt
kommen sondern dass wir voranschreiten
in einer allianz derjenigen
industriestaaten die dafür sorgen dass
die technologie bereit steht und das
heißt dann selber früher aus fossiler
energie auszusteigen und die technologie
für saubere industrie auf den weg zu
bringen
und wenn die beiden anderen nicht
mitgehen würde es dann eine
ampelkoalition brechen
dann könnte so eine koalition nicht
zustande kommen aber wir haben uns im
sondierungs papier ja bereits darauf
verständigt weil ansonsten würden wir ja
bestehendes völkerrecht brechen dass wir
die pariser klimaziele als grundlage
nehmen das bundesverfassungsgericht hat
im frühsommer ja noch mal deutlich
gemacht dass das nicht nur eine
umweltpolitische aufgabe ist sondern
dass es um schutz der freiheit
zukünftiger generationen geht und
deswegen muss diese bundesregierung eine
klima regierung sein wo sich das waren
beitrag ja auch schon deutlich nicht nur
das auswärtige amt das umweltministerium
und entwicklungshilfeministerium drum
kümmern sondern eben auch alle anderen
ressorts in der nächsten deutschen
bundesregierung jetzt lesen wir frau
berbalk allerdings von erheblicher
missstimmung sogar von einem eklat in
der arbeitsgruppe klima bei den ampel
verhandlungen die grünen verhandler
sollen laut bild am sonntag aus protest
die gespräche verlassen haben was ist
denn da los
wie das manchmal so ist wissen zeit und
mehr als diejenigen die vielleicht mit
am tisch sitzen aber wenn 300 personen
verhandeln und vor allen dingen darüber
verhandeln wie wir massiv geld in die
hand nehmen um unseren industriestandort
deutschland klimaneutral zu gestalten
wird zugleich aber mit blick auf soziale
gerechtigkeit digitalisierung auch
finanzielle mittel brauchen dann geht es
manchmal heftig zur sache aber
bekanntermaßen wo reibung entsteht kommt
dann ja irgendwann auch der auftrieb und
wir brauchen einen gemeinsamen aufbruch
nicht nur beim klimaschutz sondern
insgesamt mit blick auf unsere
gesellschaft
und deswegen bringen wie er ich glaube
alle drei parteien mit allem was wir
haben so heftig gerade darum dass wir
diesen aufbruch jetzt auch gestalten
können haben wir denn soviel zeit
nochmal hat so ein bisschen den eindruck
als bürger dieses landes das ist ein
bisschen wie bei corona jetzt aktuell
wir sind in so einer zwischenphase was
die regierung angeht kommt der
regierungswechsel jetzt eigentlich auch
beim klima letztlich zum denkbar
ungünstigsten zeitpunkt
hätten wir vor sechs jahren und deswegen
eher wenig das immer so oft dass die
klimakonferenz von paris vor sechs
jahren war hätten wir damals schon ein
deutliches bekenntnis zum kohleausstieg
gehabt da hat aber die damalige große
koalition gesagt das wort wohl noch
nicht meinem mund nehmen dann werden wir
auch beim ausbau der erneuerbaren
energien jetzt auf einem anderen weg
aber das heißt ja nicht dass man jetzt
nichts tut dies weil vorher nicht genug
getan wurde ja und dann deswegen müssen
wir jetzt unsere anstrengung vertrag
fortgeführt kann nach vorne gucken ihr
kollege robert habeck der sagt
möglicherweise klappt das gar nicht mit
dem eigentlich gesteckten zeitplan also
in der woche nach dem sechsten dezember
olaf scholz zum bundeskanzler zu wählen
ist das einfach ein gut gemachter bluff
oder sind sie auch der meinung dass wir
noch viel länger zeit brauchen mit mit
ihren verhandlungen
die lage derzeit nicht um klimaschutz
sondern bei corona ist zu dramatisch als
dass wir dürfen würden sondern sie haben
ja gerade selber angesprochen wir sind
gerade in einer katastrophalen situation
mit blick auf die pandemische lage in
unserem land deswegen ist jetzt die
volle energie vor allem darauf die
maßnahmen zum schutz vor neuinfektionen
weiter an zu schärfen auch gesetzlich
weiter an zu schärfen und zugleich
diesen koalitionsvertrag auf dem weg zu
bringen und alles beide machen wir mit
sehr großer ernsthaftigkeit aber die
dramatik gerade mit blick auf die
inzidenz zahlen die ist in diesen tagen
einfach oberste priorität auf jeden fall
und da müssen wir noch kurz über dieses
thema natürlich auch reden bei der frage
nämlich wie ankommen gegen die neue
pandemiewelle da stellen sich auch grüne
gesundheitsminister und ihr grüner
ministerpräsident in baden württemberg
jetzt gegen das was die ampel im
bundestag vor hat haben sie da ihre
erste krise bevor die koalition
überhaupt steht nein sondern alle bei
uns in der partei und ich glaube auch in
vielen anderen parteien ringen jetzt
aufs heftigste darum wie wir
rechtsgrundlagen dafür schaffen dass die
verschärften maßnahmen und ich sage dass
hier sehr deutlich wir brauchen weiter
verschärfte maßnahmen nicht nur zwei
gehen man muss jetzt auch über 2g plus
nachdenken wir müssen deutlich machen
dafür mit dem bus land voran kommen das
heißt überall jetzt mobile impf teams
auf den weg zu bringen und darin wir
natürlich gemeinsam darum was ist die
beste rechtsgrundlage wir glauben dass
wir rechtlich stabil das ganze bauen
müssen und dafür über den
maßnahmenkatalog welche schutzmaßnahmen
müssen jetzt überall ergriffen werden
das heißt dann auch zum beispiel jetzt
noch zu ergänzen dass wir natürlich auch
kontakt reduzierung brauchen dass wir
das jetzt auf den weg bringen aber das
muss so sein dass es vor gerichten dann
auch bestand hat viele diskussionen also
noch wenig zeit gleichzeitig frau
berbalk herzlichen dank nach berlin
danke ihnen auch und damit sind wir beim
thema dass doch wieder große sorgen
macht die dramatischen warnungen aus den
krankenhäusern die appelle auf
weihnachtsfeiern zu verzichten die
meldungen über teil lockt downs in
unseren nachbarländern
wir dachten das bliebe uns künftig
erspart aber es ist alles wieder da nur
dass wir diesmal noch die
sondersituation haben dass die eine
regierung nicht mehr so richtig im amt
ist und die andere noch überhaupt nicht
und sich beide seiten bereits heftig
streiten cristianos und der lagebericht
der kostenlose bürger test er ist zurück
nach gerade mal einem monat viele kleine
testzentren fahren jetzt wieder hoch wie
hier in hannover ich persönlich bin
geimpft und lass mich trotzdem tasten
weiß ja auch immer wieder berichte über
durchbruch infektionen gibt diese
vermeintliche sicherheit in der sich
viele geimpfte wiegen auf ihren zweig
paradies
da sollte man doch eher vorsichtig sein
genauso wie die natürlich die noch keine
impfung haben
45.000 81 neuinfektionen meldet das
robert koch institut heute 11 1079 mehr
als vergangenen samstag die inzidenz so
hoch wie nie bei zwei
177,4 besonders hoch sind dazu die
zahlen im südosten deutschlands über
1000 die inzidenz werte in vier
landkreisen in bayern und sachsen wie
hier in der sächsischen schweiz
osterzgebirge in pirna wird kontrolliert
täglich mit bis zu zehn teams
es geht um die einhaltung der
zweijährigen die kontrolle heute fühlt
sich für diese geschäftsinhaberin
unverhältnismäßig an
doch in sachsen setzen sie auf kontrolle
denn die inzidenz werte schießen in die
höhe auch in dresden hat andreas wünsche
im elbe garten ein paar turbulente tage
hinter sich gerade hagelt es
stornierungen bei familien und
weihnachtsfeiern und wir wissen nicht
was noch kommt wollte die momentane
krone schutz vor und sachsen erst mal
bis 25 11 geht und was danach kommt weiß
momentan leider nehmen der 25 november
das bisher geplante ende der
epidemischen lage die länder hätten
stand jetzt dann weniger spielraum für
strikte maßnahmen shutdowns und
ausgangssperren sieht vor allem die fdp
nicht mehr es ist ein missverständnis in
der debatte dass das aufheben der
sogenannten epidemischen lage mit
tatenlosigkeit zu tun hatte sondern ganz
im gegenteil das ist nur ein
rechtsbegriff der sonderbefugnisse der
regierung begründet worauf wir uns alle
einstellen müssen ist das konsequentere
maßnahmen gibt tempo beim impfen und
beim boosten etwa zweig regeln dort wo
es regional nötig ist mindestens also es
geht um mehr konsequenz und nicht um
weniger konsequent
konsequenz so hört man aus der union spd
und von teilen der grünen wäre es aber
die epidemische lage doch zu verlängern
am donnerstag sollen im bundestag die
ampel pläne noch einmal auf den tisch
und bei unseren nachbarn im westen
versetzt die regierung ihren bürgern
einen ich zitiere den
ministerpräsidenten harten schlag für
einige wochen das erste land in
westeuropa das wieder in einen
teilweisen lockdown geht mehr dazu hat
jetzt keine weise lockt dann für
mindestens drei wochen seit heute müssen
in den niederlanden restaurants und
supermärkte ab 20 uhr schließen die
meisten anderen geschäfte schon ab 18
uhr außerdem dürfen sich in
privatwohnungen höchstens vier gäste
aufhalten gegen die maßnahmen gab es in
den haag gewaltsame proteste die polizei
löste die demonstration mit
wasserwerfern auf
an der grenze zwischen polen und belarus
ist die lage der migranten weiter
dramatisch in dem gebiet wurde die
leiche eines jungen syrers gefunden die
todesursache steht noch nicht fest
unterdessen hat russlands präsident
putin jede verantwortung für die krise
bestritten die eu beschuldigt den kreml
belarus dabei zu helfen migranten an
ihrer außengrenze zu schleusen dort
campieren mehrere tausend menschen unter
freiem himmel genaue zahlen gibt es
nicht weil hilfsorganisationen und
reportern der zugang verwehrt wird
sieben wochen nach der landtagswahl in
mecklenburg vorpommern ist der weg für
die künftige landesregierung frei in
syrien spd und linke ihren
koalitionsvertrag unterzeichnet
kernziele seien eine starke wirtschaft
und der klimaschutz so ministerpräsident
in spe sich die anfang der woche im
landtag wiedergewählt werden soll
das sonntagswetter wird november lich
gemischt hier sind die aussichten von
der ems bis zum erzgebirge zeigt sich
hin und wieder die sonne sonst bleibt es
meist trübe im süden kann es auch
sprühregen geben 7 bis 12 grad auch die
neue woche startet mit ruhigen
herbstwetter soll heißen häufig
hochnebel und wenig sonne am sonntag
kommt von nordwesten her regen auf das
ganze bei 5 bis 13 grad und noch kurz
die zeilen formel samstagslotto wie
immer ohne gewähr
3 4 610 25 42 superzahl 0 weitere
gewinnzahlen gibt es unter lotto zdf de
und im zdf text auf seite 55 6
argentinien ist mit sicherheit eines der
schönsten länder der welt buenos aires
eine stadt in die sich generationen von
besuchern verliebt haben teil des
charmes war immer auch das nostalgisch
antiquierte das melancholisch morbide
das jedem aber sofort auch klar macht
leicht haben es dieses land und seine
bewohner schon lange nicht mehr gehabt
an diesem wochenende sind
parlamentswahlen die argentinierinnen
und argentinien würden so gerne einen
ausweg wählen aus wirtschaftskrise armut
arbeitslosigkeit inflation pandemie und
sie wissen doch das wird so einfach
nicht funktionieren aus buenos aires
berichtet unser korrespondent christoph
bröcker rat
monika hat noch kein abendessen für ihre
drei kinder und auch kein geld dafür
aber zwei alte strampler kleidung gegen
nahrung gibt mir bitte öl und nudeln
dafür
wir sind auf einen tauschmarkt in einem
vorort von buenos aires immer mehr
menschen in argentinien sind auf solche
geschäfte angewiesen auch monika seit
sie ihren job als haushälterin verloren
hat
die kinder brauchen die kleidung eher
nicht mehr öl nudeln und reis aber
können wir gebrauchen
die anhaltende wirtschaftskrise hat man
es schwer gezeichnet die gassen der
innenstadt wo sich sonst tausende
tummeln sind kaum noch wiederzuerkennen
unzählige restaurants geschäfte und
bürogebäude stehen leer
[Musik]
argentinien befindet sich in einer krise
es ist ein land mit 52 prozent
inflationsrate im letzten jahr mit 40
prozent der bevölkerung in armut ein
land dessen bruttoinlandsprodukt im
letzten jahr um zehn prozentpunkte
gesunken ist
mit blick auf die bevorstehenden
parlamentswahlen versprechen alle
parteien besserung doch eine schnelle
lösung kann es gar nicht geben vor allem
die korona pandemie wird nach um den
lockdown abzufedern und den ärmsten zu
helfen hatte die regierung immer mehr
geld gedruckt und damit die inflation
noch verstärkt der wert des peso sinkt
die arme viertel wachsen und der
mittelstand der arbeitsplätze schaffen
müsste verzweifelt
pablo und rektor sind als letzte übrig
geblieben in der metallfabrik am
stadtrand von buenos aires in der seit
fast 50 jahren arbeiten ihre kollegen
mussten alle g firmenchef fernando
konnte sie nicht mehr bezahlt wegen der
inflation rasen löhne und rohstoffpreise
in die höhe langfristige planung und
profite sind so kaum möglich
ich bin ein wenig hoffnungslos denn wir
haben weniger arbeitskräfte und damit
weniger wachstumsmöglichkeiten ich weiß
nicht wie sich das ändern soll ich sehe
keinen schnellen ausweg
[Musik]
wir treffen noch einmal monika vom
tauschmarkt gemeinsam mit anderen frauen
sammelt sie recycling müll anfangs habe
sie sich für diese arbeit geschämt sagt
sie doch das musste sie überwinden
wenn wir in einen müllcontainer steigen
müssen steigen wir ein wenn wir zupacken
müssen packen wir zu für mich ist es das
geld das zählt es ist geld das ich für
meine kinder mit nach hause bringe
doch selbst der müll den monika sammelt
ist weniger geworden weil weniger
konsumiert wird die krise ist ganz unten
angekommen in argentinien
werden argentinien bei der staatlichen
bank ort de la nation 10.000 pesos
anlegt bekommt für ein jahr 37 prozent
zinsen hat wegen über 50 prozent
inflation am ende aber doch viel weniger
zahlen die für sentimentale verklärung
keinen raum mehr lassen leider
wir danken ganz herzlich für ihr
interesse an diesem samstagabend und
sagen tschüss bis morgen hinein lange
matches
[Musik]